as I sent a picture of of Brian's feet
yeah Georgie you back the [ __ ] we're
regressing with your style we're going
back to jean sandals no no I it's just
hot today and I threw them on in a hurry
that's all I want to wear pants with
sandals in my house
really nope I want to get the mail like
that
what about Burke's you go Burt you know
that's good she put out a line he
wouldn't he bought a pair of boots with
a buckle on him from Gucci never warm
again you warm once I think right I wear
them all the time you do if ever I'm not
wear boots this do I wear moans oh
really yeah I love those boots have you
ever tried Burke's Birkenstock well you
got a Burke
too white for me nice top oh you got a
Burke coming from me dude is different
it's not like flip-flops is not like
slides
it's bird that's wide open it's like a
combination skis got double straps you
actually feel you could do something you
could like you could fight if you need
like a real you know it's clear what can
you run if you need to yes Burke's
comest dude is a communist why are those
Burke's 500 [ __ ] they're made to your
foot nah man I don't do dance sandals
just so no no that's not saying that's
how you got to stop that's Burke's
that's a different girl looks pretty
cool hey Bryce right they're killing it
that's it that be
dude that's refined what are you gonna
wear if your nose there's a bird inside
there is a Birkenstocks tour on a bikini
hey hey so get them let's get you to
Meyers my Tevas but don't wear though
yeah I think you can you're past that
you're more refined than that yeah
you're a Berk you know what you better
person
yeah you lose me yeah but you could
Burke that's the thing that you don't
realize you can Burke it my toes dog is
different it's your choice or even
vulnerable and you start not vulnerable
summer's over bro
allegedly the ledge protects your toe
you see at the front there's that little
edge you're not stubbing your toe ha
even one time there are not even one
time you step in your toe and your heel
there's that little hook right there
that's day look like Jesus shoes yeah
say what it look like Jesus hey soos in
an emergency maybe but that is you never
have an emergency there's a different
life that's a boat collared shirt huh to
you Nick bro that's too much that's too
much that's it that's a commitment
that's too much well dude dude I'm
leaving Tuesday night let's go shopping
no last night I had a very uncomfortable
situation we're at the club
yeah what happened I I did that he's
laughs and right now I already I it's
gotta be I did stand up I did stand
whatever I de stand up how about ya
Jeremih I'm leaving I'm about to walk
out scot-free we had a great time go to
another spot everything's gonna be great
Laugh Factory and Emily at the store
goes hey do you want to a spot in the
main room Joey's on it bears on it Greg
Fitzsimmons on it I was like hell yeah
of course and we're walking through the
main room and she goes yeah you know
it's um it's like it's a benefit for
people on the spectrum and I'm like hold
on it is [ __ ] people here like once
to go cuz I just don't I was like I'll
just pass I don't know exactly how to do
it you know and then she was no no no
it's like people in a halfway house to
me halfway house is you were you know
had some drugs you maybe we're in jail
locked up and they're trying to bring
back a person I usually say drop my I go
to drug addict we're drug every doesn't
matter right no way so I go halfway
that's okay I'm walking in the back to
some guys with like beards like face
tattoos oh my god these some rough guys
are trying to get the life back together
and I'm excited because I'm like these
guys aren't gonna be finished [ __ ] I can
[ __ ] go in [ __ ] yeah
I get brought up onstage I do a couple
jokes things are going really well and
then I go into this bit there's [ __ ]
Ben right and you see how like wine is
now yeah multiply quiet it is now by
like a thousand that's what that full
room felt like really it got real quiet
I'm like this is weird but you were
crushing before that cuz I saw you early
on it was good I'm not I'm not the guy
who like says overkilled ever say like
I'm the most critical self it was going
it was
oh well yeah it was going hard took a
little turn and then I would say I got
it back up to about like 50% right
that's a hard hole to dig out of it we
were little artists we were a team
I walk off stage and Diaz goes uh he
goes yes yes hey uh what why'd you
closer to [ __ ] joke it's a benefit for
retouch yeah it's for [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's okay kid don't worry buddy dude
balls man to do that [ __ ] joke but I
went pretty well not 50% bro I go back
as a smaller part rank don't know it was
or just staring at you some people were
there just to see burr yeah well right
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] is they
just see bill Birds so I think all those
people like ah this is awesome and then
all these people that are taking care of
a [ __ ] at home are like what the [ __ ]
is going on I'm supported sued the first
comic that went on I think was like
mentally challenged but I didn't know I
thought he was just a comic because you
know comics registry you know comic can
be awkward a little bit yes yes yes I
just thought he was awkward and um I
think I came talk about our interaction
but uh I felt so [ __ ] bad yeah I felt
so far you went to the laughs factor
after that I went to a laugh after that
yeah honestly the audience was more
[ __ ]
I couldn't believe it who those chosen
one night due to the more that was
expected that one you know is coming I
walked in Jose okay close eyes here I
saw the arm canes out front I know it's
so specific I don't know never retarder
was just everything who is the thing was
all the things yeah now it's just taking
on a different kind of power right oh my
god dude your shoes are [ __ ] yeah it
was just like a and if they were they
were it's like you never knew when you
went home
you're like wolf in front of everyone
we're like shut the [ __ ] up no they're
not here and you get home like I did
dude the food sucks in Egypt man yeah
hey but also no [ __ ] dude
yo but yes [ __ ] like I put no [ __ ] no no
you've been there for six thousand years
you can figure out [ __ ] food nothing
that named something they've invented
there's nothing the pyramids well that's
how I know that he's an alien it's not
aliens but it's not them it's probably
white dudes it might have been white
guys problem I've been like the British
some of buggers from one day it was a
gift
real talk no there's no way like
everything about that [ __ ] the pyramids
it just blew my [ __ ] mind
that's the most impressive thing I've
ever seen in my like I literally you're
the only person every person I let see
the Paris Mike do they're kind of small
was it [ __ ] there's McDonald's like outs
out front when people have [ __ ] on the
pyramids almost every Rhino it's guys
their parents like whoa what are your
other one state permits names the muddy
Kalin for sure no way yeah I was doing
some operation other half yeah we take
it out now
I've never heard great things about the
pyramids I've always heard they're
overrated
huh but you love them done they're the
most underrated thing I've ever seen in
my entire life they are the most marette
it questions your idea of reality it
makes you question reality you're
watching it and in live you we were
questioning how could this happen like I
don't even think about human progress
the same way after looking at the
parallel Wow
this is how I think the pyramids
happened I think there were some humans
they built the pyramids they developed
these cool you know - technology that
allowed them to do it those humans died
out and because we didn't live in this
like global society where everybody
knows what's going on when you died snow
did all your technology oh yeah you
can't tweet out right so then another
group of humans thousands of years later
the one that we call the Egyptians now
they pull up they see some dope [ __ ] and
they're like yo last hours cuz you would
claim whatever is yours understand and
then every group that walked up on it
just claimed it the Greeks the Romans
the Jews anybody who pulled up on it was
like yeah we made that that was us
that's our people but there's no way in
[ __ ] hell any humans they're like you
don't subscribe you the alien right you
know I think we just say alien when we
don't know how things happen in our
reality and that's why I'm talking about
question reality like these [ __ ]
things the bricks themselves are so
massive there's no way in hell you could
move those bricks and you know that they
didn't get those bricks from that place
they're not like seventeen kilometers
away that cross the river with them yeah
like there's all this insane [ __ ]
suspect this white suspect you know what
makes something a civilization a group
of people a civilization writing write
that is what made the Egyptians of
civilization writing the hieroglyphs
yeah so how do you write about
everything but how to build that that's
why they say aliens though even if
aliens did it they would write the
aliens did it and I know someone's gonna
point at a hieroglyph where they're like
an alien looking thing no you go in
detail about how those [ __ ] aliens it
you wanna do a shot at theater would you
want to detail you [ __ ] corn but
you're not go to detail how you build
this there's nothing here the idea that
they say that Jews built it absolutely
[ __ ] because if you look at the Old
Testament they go into detail about how
to build a temple every the the cloth
has to hang two centimeters below that
there's a specific minor details how to
build a temperature
how to do know writing whatsoever nobody
else replicates it and you know what you
see this [ __ ] in Mexico in other parts
of the world it's stacked up raw son
that's what it is but at one point time
was perfectly flat oh they chipped away
it at over years using it to make
weapons etc this was perfectly straight
if there's a mock-up of what they're
supposed to look like back in the day so
these things we have on our dollar bills
too well because that's strange
now the Masons the people who basically
created America they were inspired by
the Egyptians and they think they're
like philosophy is that every once in a
while yeah this is what they thought
this is what they look like back in the
day perfectly flat white if you're
talking about the Luxor that's what it
looked like how do you think they got
that idea when it's supposed to be white
there was blaim stone Sun it was perfect
white limestone that's what it's made
out of six thousand years you get a
little rust should order no dude I'm
telling you it is you cannot you cannot
imagine it now it I'll look at the
pictures looks pretty sweet yeah a
little bit here's the other oh it's
where Isis is in North Africa like mmm
[ __ ] Isis is done bro good man my
boy had this [ __ ] joke that I just
thought I gotta send on this tag but
like here's this thing about how like
turtles you know with the the plastic
straws like how the plastic straw thing
is oh yeah cause they eat him know he
goes it's he was this fake they go what
do you mean is fake he's like he cuz he
goes you're telling me a turtle could be
swimming and then a straw is coming at
him so fast in the wreck that it lodges
in its [ __ ] nose is that what you
want me to believe so so the tag I want
to give her is like no PETA that's
Peters Jesse's mullet like their stage
harvest and they do eat the plastic bag
so they think they're jellyfish ah turn
over the straw yes terrific bags here
and also they live to 200 it's probably
time to kill themselves like if they
live too long this is a long ride only I
must mean that slow for that long per
car to live like the arctic shark or the
Iceland just
we've been around looking for killers I
feel like that tell people become back
as an arctic shark we're gonna live 500
years in this cold weather and you're
just gonna swim around look I really
believe they've never seen - yeah I
really believe Stalin and Hitler and Pol
Pot and all those colors sharks I'm
serious
so if you kill them it's how do you live
500 years they did carbon dating on the
inside of the I lived four hundred
[ __ ] years what you know you're
you're a ghost
you're a true ghost yeah you're blind in
ice water looking around for what you
know friends yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]